[Music]
hello and welcome to playstation grenade
ladies and gentlemen the final event to
end the fortnite and marvel crossover
season is here on tuesday
it's so close to the end to get ready
for this world changing event i've gone
back through the last 14 weeks of
updates to bring you a full recap
of everything that happened no spoilers
only facts please think about using code
adamaru to support content like this
and now sit your butt down for 10
minutes let's recap the nexus war before
galactus
attacks oh quick question what skin are
you wearing to the event
it's tough to answer isn't it bet you
can't guess mine
[Music]
week zero i know this is a strange place
to start but before the season
officially began
a huge crater was spotted over by salty
springs
inside was our first proof of a marvel
invasion
thor's hammer laying dormant we tried in
vain to lift monomer
tell me i cannot say that word mjolnir
mjolnir
we tried in vain to lift it but it was
not to be the comic book told us about
the devourer of worlds
a giant being sent to gather powers to
fight an even more evil force
the black winter but that's a tale for
another time
the power galactus needs is held within
five worlds
which he consumes without any thought of
the inhabitants
but something happened in the vacuum of
space
galactus saw the power infinite held on
the island during the end
he saw the nexus point galactus was
already on his way here
luckily thor the herald of thunder
accompanied galactus
and traveled ahead to warner's but our
island is stuck in a loop and
thor is attacked right away as the
fighting ends
thor is unable to remember he came to
warn us about something
while his memory fades thor calls upon
lady sith
and the bifrost to summon heroes to help
earth's mightiest heroes arrive
each affected differently by the island
the question remains will they be able
to remember
galactus is coming and be prepared in
time well that was that was more
dramatic than i expected
[Music]
week one our first day in the updated
map saw some great changes
first are those scorch marks left around
by the bifrost
that's how the battle pass characters
arrived here thanks to thor
here landed doctor doom wolverine
she-hulk
mystique storm groot and the incredibly
important
tony stark aka iron man nearby is a
graveyard of sentinels these were
anti-mutant robots the x-men fought
regularly
there's talk that these may come alive
in the event so maybe keep an eye on
them that would be cool but right now
these bots have been decommissioned by
wolverine
the coolest update for me was the
inclusion of two henchmen
from season two they returned without
anyone to follow
these were found at the authority
andover in retail row up at pleasant
park dr doom moved in and renovated the
place with a castle-like home
and a statue of himself what kind of a
person built a statue of themselves
i'll tell you who people who are making
up for something victor may not be such
a big man
tony i can't say that i can i say that
can i say that is that offensive tony
stark on the other hand
has set up a makeshift base in a disused
farmhouse
and the key to the story is here the
objects around this
place tony is hard at work creating
beacons which will soon be used to bring
parts of our world
to the island to do this he's using
shield technology which can be found all
around the island
in quinjet like drop ships guided by
bots
this tech powers those beacons next over
to retail row and the place
she hulk calls home jennifer walters law
offices
made it over to the island who knew
lawyers could be superheroes i always
thought they were the bad guys
jennifer had a blood transfusion with
the real hulk and that's why she turns
green
and i hear that you won't like her when
she gets angry and remember whilst all
this is happening
a tiny dot in the sky appeared that's
galactus
he's approaching little did we know we
still have three months to wait
mini updates now hud watch it kept
growing this season with a rail added to
the edge
wow the iron man made of iron pipes and
the hayman met
up on day one of the season to share a
high five moment
which was beautiful and the last thing
we should remember about week one was
the end of the wobbly blob story
yeah i like saying wobbly blob you
should try it it's fun
the coral buddies made a home during the
previous season and evolved through
human evolution
and on the day of season 4 the nuclear
blast caused them to become half coral
creature
and half cyborg they vanished a few days
later
but we'll never forget those wobbly
blobs
[Music]
week two this week tony stark set up and
switched on
those completed beacons for days we
watched them growing power
but more on that next week five new pois
popped up during week two
ant-man's manor a trask transport
related to the x-men
and the touching tribute to wakanda and
black panther
this was also at a time when chadwick
boseman passed away
rest in peace chadwick the fifth poi is
a spot from the marvel's avengers video
game which came out a few months back
nobody played that game except me i
quite like it but i seem to be the only
one
the addition of these pois confirmed
tony stark's temporal rifts were working
but not entirely to plan what was
certain though was that earth's
mightiest heroes were on their way here
we weren't stuck to the six in the
battle pass
the introduction of pym tech could also
be very important for the event
as these vials here have the power to
shrink us but also
the power to make us giants stark is
planning something
and these places have importance hey
remember this update
the crane which was lifting a crane
which was lifting a car which fell out
of a garage on the cliff edge
well it fell down
week three this week saw the
introduction of tony stark's lab
look at the size of this update it's
mahousev
the temporal beacons we saw activated
last week have brought a whole chunk of
upstate new york to the island
stark industries is the home to iron man
suits and all his tech
but it's the garage that should grab
your attention he has begun working on a
new and improved battle bus
for the impending fight with galactus so
somehow tony stark has retained his
memories somehow
i wonder how the puddle of oil here will
one day be replaced
with our future also the cabin from
avengers end game is here
complete with a secret iron man facility
underneath
it's just like the movie is so good on a
scale of one to
three thousand how much do you love this
is it still too soon to do i love you
three thousand jokes
this update saw the introduction of a
slurp juice salesman
attracting the genome community his
first public appearance
ended in assassination
i checked on graham he's okay i know you
were worried for him
i was too hot watch had additional
chairs and pallets this week
the walls were renovated and a sick new
archway included
update on the ghost and shadow npcs they
are now in a gas station cafe having a
dance-off
this is how your mum and dad met you
know true story
camp cod lost part of its poi this week
turns out it was an
error and this was because something
else was going to be added soon it was
something strange
and it was in your neighborhood but at
this point we didn't know who to call
week 4 arrived it's a weird update the
houses at lazy lake had been rotated
no idea why a week later this was
rectified
and the basketball post at 20 cents was
stretched out
again i have no idea why i think someone
epic games may have been drinking this
week
i'm cool with that the only other update
this week are a slight closer movement
of the dude in the sky
reminding us galactus is coming week
five
this week the bromance has evolved the
former foes are now taking a break at
the hotel in lazy lake
this was a week you guys named these two
bill and ted
good choice the other subplot was the
genome slurp juice micro narrative
and the unveiling of this guy an evil
genome half cyborg thing
he was found in the basement of a
disused ghost base and plotted to take
out the island's known population
with the help of these bot things we
quickly revealed his plans to plant
explosives on slurp juice containers and
saved them all for our lord and saviour
graham the gnome
also did you notice the extra hidden
gnomes around the map gotta love the
attention to detail
there was a change to one of the marvel
pois this week the traffic transport had
been clawed open and someone had escaped
it was none other than wolverine he set
up a new life in the woodlands
going back to his predatory routes and
ruining anyone who faced him
week 5 also saw a new store built over
by the gas station near holly hedges
a superstar it was a shell inside with
nothing of note
but you all said it would be the new
seasonal store and you were right
but not just yet over at hot watch a
window was added
week six fortnight battle royale's
birthday was this week we ate cake
when week seven arrived rocket league
took over the crane house
miniature cars and trophies were found
here but only for one single week
there was also a really cool rocket
league car you could drive
in-game and the collector's stash from
guardians of the galaxy
randomly showed up on a snowy mountain
top
week eight halloween arrived in fortnite
and over the week more and more houses
caught the crypt bug and decorated
appropriately the update on the henchmen
this week they went to the dam
this was the first time it appeared as
if they were searching for something
noticing something in the distance and
actively walking towards it
only to be upset and walk back again it
was suggested they were looking for
midas
well they didn't have to wait long
because back at the authority where the
shadow henchmen once lived
the sacred gold chair returned with a
seat either side for the bros to sit
but wasn't midas eaten by a shark fyi
over at hot watch the wood was vanished
and a new floor was installed
tiles being an adult is great other
updates include a graffiti tag for the
evil genome which you guys named the
gnominator
i love that more on him next week oh and
galactus is now visible in the sky he's
close enough
to brofist the event is approaching fast
tony stark continues to build buses and
keeps evolving them each week but will
they be finished in time
[Music]
on to week nine fort nightmares arrived
everything became
foggy and spoopy everyone joined in with
more pois than ever before
updating their decorations thanks to the
superstar which as predicted
became the home of all things witchcraft
one area in particular was extra
ghoulsom
at the northernmost point near steamy
stacks there are three houses on the
cliff edge
these places were overrun by gargoyles
with glowing eyes
preying on the gnome population there
was also an easter egg here this year
the ghosts rising up and floating away
the authority was updated to the ruins
this week and
look who returned undead midas is here
some sort of ritual around the golden
chair brought him back
and now he guards the island with his
henchmen recruiting those who oppose him
the halloween update saw real witch's
huts adding to the mav
again only for a week or two we even had
witch's brooms to ride
it was fun over at hookwatch a layer of
plaster was added
yep gripping stuff the henchmen of bro
watch if you prefer are now located up
at sweaty sands
they also got into the halloween spirit
wearing pumpkin heads
they now dine out together and their
favorite spot is the taco stand
oh remember the evil genome well this
week he met his comeuppance
we found him poisoning the slurp vats
and to clean them
we dipped our junk in them okay then we
confronted the bad guy
i don't think this ended how he expected
and finally this week the update at camp
cod finally happened
to foreshadow the ghostbusters arriving
the ecto-1 hearse can be found hidden
under a cloth
in a barn striking the vehicle gave us
the iconic siren sound
and for old people that's a cool thing
[Music]
week 11 is here and the map reset all
the halloween shenanigans were gone
the air was clean again the store near
holly hedges closed down
and life continued the henchmen are now
found at craggy cliffs and are preparing
for a backpacking vacation
they pick out their own tent and boat
before going on an adventure
hut watch this week had the walls inside
the building plastered
and up at sweaty sands for one week only
the gas station was resized
and downsized just for seven days it
came back to normal
next update the genome sub story was
concluded with the passing of the
genominator
whose rocket trip ended in failure and a
memorial to his dastardly life
is now in place outside slurpee make
sure you pay your respects because
evil genome lives matter too story-wise
the galactus is another step closer he's
huge in the sky
i'm so hyped for this event iron man is
keeping one step ahead though with the
battle bus plans
just look at how sleek the battle bus is
looking
nice
week 13 arrived as did the new ps5 and
xbox series x
updates which added new animations and
lighting effects to the game
which were good the best one is how
bodies crumble
after elimination awesome touch the
biggest thing though is galactus this
week
he's crazy close right now and set on
the horizon ready to attack any second
days later he swooped underneath the
island or at least we thought he was
underneath
meanwhile tony stark finished his plan
11 weeks in the making
and finally the battle bus is no longer
an air balloon
it's a rocket fueled gamma guzzling
galactus smashing weapon
it looks like we are now prepared for
the battle to save our island
and i'm gonna be honest right now i'm
gonna fly one of these bad boys
right up galactus head watch another
coat of varnish is being added
hmm remember when hot watch was cool
yeah not so much these days
rip and one last update to the henchmen
in season four
the bromance like no other the brothers
from other mothers are now found over on
the east of the island
camping out it's a chill time for them
as they know galactus is coming
and this may be their last ever update
they sit
and contemplate their lives be sure to
sit with them
one last time before the event
[Music]
and right now it's the final week week
14 and galactus
is slowly reappearing on the island he's
currently snorkeling
for a little me time before things get
serious his huge kfc bucket head
rises slowly each day this week we also
had the bus content confirmed
it is filled with gamma weaponry could
the hulk be coming to help us
or is this jennifer's input into the war
efforts the timer now sits above us on
the helicarrier and the radio chatter
there is growing with hints to nick fury
and a secret weapon to be uncovered
but in terms of facts and updates that
was season four
in a nutshell the battle to save the
island starts on tuesday
and is promised to change the fortnite
world forever i'm adam from playstation
grenade thank you for your time and a
special thank you to those who used code
adamaru this week
i really appreciate what you do for me
i'll see you all after the event